[Musique]
ap patrice l'oise aisne je suis
président de l'association sos grammont
isolé
c'est
l'objectif c'est d'aider à rompre la
solitude et l'isolément des personnes
âgées qui sont plus en plus nombreux sur
l'île est de plus en plus en solitude
donc nous avions commencé un accueil à
pau elle est à la fête des mères dans
des familles réunionnaises quand ils
n'étaient pas invités par leur famille
on a continué par des visites des
sorties de la conversation téléphonique
et depuis deux ans la cohabitation
solidaire ou sur le principe une
personne âgée offre une chambre avec
accès cuisine salle de bain à huit dames
de compagnie en pleine folie mais montre
simplement deux heures de conversation
en soirée les présences de nuit en
semaine
sérieux et compassion ça démarre de
problèmes souvent un peu personnel il
c'est ça qui donne la foi la conviction
en isolement par rapport à ma famille à
par rapport à mes enfants
c'est toujours très difficile à vivre
j'ai toujours été proche des plus
démunis des légendes et les plus en
difficulté
[Musique]
une temps qu'ils vont bien pas de
problème dont danser s'amuser qui centre
à dire quand ils ne vont plus et maisons
de retraite est souvent la fin j'allais
dire
entre les deux il ya toute cette ce
passage où on entre en dépendance on
marche moins bien on voit moins bien et
où là il ya un grand désert c'est pour
ça qu'on a monté gramoune isolé et donc
ce qu'on ne souhaiterait notamment sur
la cohabitation solidaire que des
personnes qui les accompagnent puisse
avoir une petite indemnité une petite
allocation de 300 à 600 euros
je pense que ça c'est très important il
faut que ça ait puisse monter au plus
haut niveau
[Musique]